frédéric dabi qu'est ce qu'ils en disent
les français de ils ont un point de vue
tranché sur ce sujet il paraît que on
nous dit que 75 % des français seraient
contre une mesure comme celle là j'ai
pas de données en ce sens je vois dans
des enquêtes fait dans des grandes
métropoles comme paris ou bordeaux ou au
systématiquement la réduction de la
vitesse de 50 km heure à 30 a été
soutenue il faut voir aussi que c'est un
c'est une des rares politiques publiques
qui réussit en france pour ces quatre
dernières années n'oublions pas qu'en
moins cher exemple quand jacques quand
jacques chirac en 2002 annonce trois
chantiers prioritaires de son
quinquennat le handicap le quand la
lutte contre le cancer et la sécurité
routière on est à plus de 10000 ou onze
mille morts par an la politique menée
avec un délégué interministériel
s'articulait autour de deux grands axes
c'est à dire la sanction sur la ceinture
sur l'alcool au volant puis sur le
téléphone au volant et sur la baisse de
la vitesse c'est pas la première fois
finalement ça a quand même donné des
résultats puisque le nombre de morts a
été divisé par deux et demi malgré une
remontée au cours des dernières années
donc je considère quand même qu' il y a
eu cette politique qui a marché sur
cette jambe de baisse des vitesses
maintenant il ya aussi ce risque on en
parlait il ya quinze jours sur
l'histoire de la cigarette
l'interdiction de fumer dans le cadre
des oeuvres cinématographiques qui peut
agacer qui peut je dirais frustré le
sentiment de liberté à des français